[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis ravi d'être parmi vous ce soir
pour vous parler de mon travail je suis
artiste je pratique une forme d'art
public et cet art public qui se décline
en plusieurs catégories d'abord je suis
street artist ça fait 15 ans que je
peins des fresques murales dans le monde
entier j'ai voyagé dans le cinq
continents pour peindre des fresques
murales et montrer mon travail dans des
galeries et en parallèle de ça je porte
un maquillage un peu étrange avez vous
vu
les deux traits que d'habitude on
retrouverait sur un visage de femme au
niveau des sourcils ou au niveau de
l'eye liner et ben je l'aimais là pour
moi c'est une manière de souligner
l'absurdité des codes esthétiques
pourquoi en fait le maquillage féminins
traditionnels serait plus acceptable
quand ces deux traits sont situés dans
une certaine partie du visage et puis
tout à coup quand ça devient linverse de
la féminité ça bouleverse tout pourquoi
la féminité est définie par ses codes
pourquoi la masculinité est définie par
tous ses codes c'est une absurdité que
je cherche à dénoncer et à souligner
tous les jours me présentant au monde
quand j'ai pas de masque comme ça ça
fait partie de ma pratique artistique
activistes aussi de créer un lien social
avec des gens que je connais pas du tout
dans les transports en commun dans
l'avion dans la rue au supermarché tous
les matins en présentant comme ça au
monde je souligne cette différence et je
m'ouvre un dialogue avec tous ces gens
que je ne connais pas
un dialogue autour de la définition des
normes de la normativité les codes du
genre et aussi de la liberté qu'on
s'accordent ou pas à se présenter au
monde comme il nous plaît
ça fait bientôt huit ans que je porte
cette moustache tous les jours ça fait
huit ans que tous les matins je me
prépare comme vous tous et toutes devant
le miroir en coiffant m'habillant comme
il me plaît et en me maquillant comme il
me plaît mon travail artistique
il a été inspiré de beaucoup de choses
bon le street art vous avez déjà vu un
peu ce que ça donne mais moi
personnellement c'est pas d'autres
street artist o2 d'autres personnes qui
faisaient de l'art urbain qui m'ont
inspiré c'est la tradition par exemple
des masques que j'ai découverte quand
j'étais ado la tradition des masques
elle est hyper intéressante parce qu'en
fait c'est une tradition qui existe dans
toutes les cultures du monde et pour moi
c'était hyper intéressant de pouvoir
découvrir quelque chose que tous les
humains avaient en commun que tout le
monde pouvait comprendre
j'ai grandi en étant enfant et ado
bombardé d'image dans l'espace public de
corps féminin idéal idéalisé des corps
mince valide blanc
fragile et forte à la fois
avec du caractère mais discrète
et je me suis pas reconnu là dedans et
j'ai eu aussi vu une forme de cruauté en
fait dans cette espèce de propagande
esthétique où on nous dit qu'il faut
être comme ça que pour être heureux être
heureuse il faut être comme ci comme ça
et que le physique des termine
finalement beaucoup de choses et je
trouvais ça très réducteur et vraiment
dérangeant
de quoi je me suis mise à peindre j'ai
toujours été fasciné par le portrait
j'ai aimé les peintures de frida kahlo
j'ai adoré les portraits de fernando
botero j'ai flashé sur le travail de
librairies qui était un performeur qui
se maquillent est aussi avec des
maquillages complètement farfelue pour
sortir dans des clubs avec des tenues
incroyables qui était au croisement des
genres s'y est tous ces gens et
questionner des choses qui me paraissait
vraiment intense est importante
comment on se représente soi même quel
est notre identité
au cours de mes voyages je rencontre
beaucoup de gens d'autres artistes ou
alors des gens lambda que je croise dans
la rue
des gens de tous les âges de toutes les
origines de toutes les classes de tous
les milieux et je vois que tout le monde
a un peu en commun aussi cette idée de
savoir qui on est il ya un grand
philosophe
antiquités chez plus trop qui l'a dit
connais toi toi même
bah ouais je trouvais ça intéressant et
en discutant avec d'autres gens et en
travaillant sur territoire de masques et
de maquillage je me suis dit je peux
créer des formes d'être et de la
visibilité pour d'autres personnes ou
d'autres visage dans l'espace public je
peux prendre moi-même aussi en tant que
personne cet espace public en me
déplaçant comme il me semble bon et en
me présentant comme il me semble juste
et en accord avec moi-même
mais cette histoire d'identité
elle est complexe un jour en discutant
avec une retraitée maryse qui habitent
dans les cévennes et qui adore faire des
supers confiture de figues
on parler de féminisme toutes les deux
et je disais maryse c'est quand même
dommage parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'entre ta génération des années 70 où
il s'est passé tellement de choses est
la mienne il ya comme un vide c'est
comme si on avait été obligé de tout
reprendre à zéro quand métaux a démarré
et elle me dit oh mais tu sais nous on a
eu la force quand on a eu la pilule puis
après moi j'avais pas rester dans la
lutte toute ma vie j'ai fait ma vie j'ai
eu des enfants j'ai un mari j'ai eu un
travail bien notre travail
j'ai évolué dans ma vie j'ai été plein
de choses puis au fur et à mesure qu'on
se parle elle me dit mais tu sais
parfois je sais pas tellement comment
définirais ce que je suis la mère de mes
filles est-ce que je suis l'ex de
mesmari ce que je suis cet ancien
professionnel qui travaille est
brillamment dans l entreprise où est ce
que je suis cette retraitée aujourd'hui
qui se la coulent douce dans les
cévennes je ne sais pas qui je suis
et ça m'a touché et je me suis dit mais
finalement peut-être que tout ça ce que
tu viens de me dire c'est toi
on peut être à la fois dans ce rôle
professionnel ou familial et puis aussi
être passionné de confiture et puis
aussi avoir plein d'autres choses qui
finalement pourrait paraître
contradictoire et ça m'a fait penser à
une métaphore d'une tresse
cette presse elle serait composée de
milliers de brun
des brins qui s'emmêle parfois de
manière harmonieuse parfois son
ébouriffés
ses traits de personnalité qu'on a ça
peut être notre tempérament ça peut être
l'éducation qu'on a reçue ça peut être
notre milieu ça peut être notre
expérience de vie
nos faits marquants pourquoi on préfère
la vanille au chocolat pourquoi on
préfère se baigner ou se doucher tous
c'est petit frère en fait forme une
tresse et cette tresse c'est nous
parfois dans cette presse il ya des
choses qu'on aime pas trop on se
surprend parfois on se découvre en fait
c'est un peu le travail d'une vie
finalement de s'apprendre de se
découvrir et 7 13 parfois elle a des
bras qui ne plaisent pas des choses qui
le met mal à l'aise ou des situations
dans lesquelles on a eu une attitude
qu'on n'aurait pas cru ou alors on a dit
un truc
constitué pourquoi je dis cela ça nous
est tous arrivé
et donc du coup ce que je trouvais
intéressant par rapport à maryse c'est
de lui dire qu'en fait ces masques
sociaux qu'elle avait l'impression de
porter en étant une mer où une ancienne
professionnelle de sa profession ou une
citoyenne dans ce petit village des
cévennes c'est masculin ne servent pas à
la cacher ses masques la révèle ces
masques sont une partie d'elle ça m'a
fait penser à des amis drag queen qui en
se maquillant révéler une partie
d'eux-mêmes et c'était pas du tout une
manière de se cacher c'était une manière
d'être soi
et je trouve que c'est intéressant que
le maquillage le masque une étymologie
commune finalement pour moi servent à me
révéler dans mon travail artistique et
dans ma vie quotidienne et ses masques
font partie de ma 13,7 presse elle est
fluide l émouvante
parfois elle est bien faite elle paraît
cohérente parfois elle est fait à
l'envers elle paraît paradoxal il ya
deux moments où dans ma vie il ya des
bruns qui sont arrivés d'autres qui sont
partis comme pour vous tous et toutes
et puis ça m'a amené à me demander
finalement ce travail sur l'identité
si je pouvais finalement trouvé une
forme d'accomplissement dans cette
fluidité
si je pouvais y trouver une forme de
d'être en accord avec moi même
d'accepter en fait ces paradoxes
d'accepter que ces brins sont multiples
et paradoxaux et parfois ébouriffés
parfois lisse
et ça m'a poussé à me demander
finalement dans ce monde si cruel
où on se jugent beaucoup où on a honte
parfois où on remet ses masques sociaux
pour s'arranger bon parce qu'il faut
bien bosser parce qu'il faut bien être
en société il faut bien être dans une
famille
tous ces masques sociaux sont nous
et ils font partie de nous autant qu'on
les aime ou qu'on les aime pas ça fait
partie de cette totalité cette tresse et
cette tresse là pour moi il suffit juste
de pouvoir l'avoir
l'accepter
accepter toute cette complexité et
accepter que dans ce monde de jugement
d'insécurité ou d'inégalités
oser être soi est une force est osé
voire cette tresse et l'accepter pour
moi je les remettrai de pouvoir aller
vers soir
merci
[Applaudissements]